everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is the askgaryvee show live in our
London office at vaynermedia we have a
audience in front of us
you guys can clap real quick and and as
you can tell I have a very attractive
athletic looking man to the right of me
left for you and so I'm gonna allow him
to you're welcome and then allow him to
uh I'm gonna try not to look at your
pretty blue eyes too much why don't you
introduce yourself to the live audience
and the audience watching at home create
a little context I've got a couple of
questions we'll open it up to the
audience and we'll do our thing so thank
you everybody for coming my name is
Danny Williams
I play for Huddersfield Town it's in the
Premier League and I used to play for
reading for four years before before I
wasn't reading I used to play for sure
in Germany for Hoffenheim and for
Freiburg and my dad is American my mom
is German but I was born and raised in
Germany as you can hear but I played for
the u.s. national team as well and
that's all about it really
so let's take it way back obviously it's
this episode's a lot of fun for me for
many many different reasons one being in
the UK office is a lot of fun too
I'm on this quest to discover what is
going to be my proper football team that
I support and will get and we're gonna
Spurs are in a very big lead I'll give
you the details on that
obviously we're coming on the back of
the World Cup the u.s. did not make it I
have a son that I'm excited to get into
proper football the culture of proper
football eSports is exploding it takes
me back to my thesis of why football is
poppin in America in comparison to all
the other times because of a game called
FIFA that came out for Sega Genesis in
94 there's a lot of places I want to go
with you from your perspective for my
audience which is more marketing in
business and things of that nature but
before we get until all of that how I'd
like to set a little bit more context
with you how did your football career
start so you were born in Germany and
what happens like immediately you have a
football and buy your foot because your
dad liked it or how did it go down
that's much my dad because he's American
so your grandfather on your mom's side
[Music]
and my daddy was like what are you doing
like I wanted to play basketball of like
American football or whatever and he was
in Germany
[Music]
no but I need this because this is gonna
clearly be the best part of this episode
one more time where does your dad from
in the u.s. he's from New York okay so
your dad who's from New York you're
telling me that somehow he got to
Germany probably on a plane yeah but
after a little while he became so
fearful of flying that he's never gone
back because he's scared to fly yeah
well so are you
years are me like getting better on all
the Americans nor we mix raise kids from
Jersey like the woman they like blank
eyes and yeah so the minute he came back
the second time my mum she was like
listen you need to stay here
like I will not let you go and then
basically it started and ever since you
stayed in Germany he told me many times
that he regrets it that he stayed his
biggest dream was to live in California
but they met my mom and they had me and
then her son stayed there and that's the
story and he's still in Germany right
now how was your dad he is born in 58 so
I want to see 50 yeah
so 60 yeah someplace but while some do
that I mean I know how it works so so
wait so fine so you get a ball at 3 your
mom puts it by your foot and what you
gravitate towards it immediately yeah
there's some I mean the local sport of
favorites born I think in oil is of
course Robin and if all the kids stay
they stay out late and play playing
football and were you good at it right
away
were you always naturally good or did
you have a spurt at some point no I was
or all like with all the people next to
me and then I was army played football
and I was still better than them and
then they told me that any listen I
think you should join the team like the
local team my mom supported it and then
I went there and they told me listen
Danny you're a bit too fat I travel I
think if you have to eat less chocolate
and you know come off the sprite and all
the stuff and come back in a year
so I did that actually and then I came
back within a year and yeah I think
started my girls hotel I was maybe like
five I would say five six is like yeah
yeah so we started then and I was I was
like this is my Germany is good at
proper football they they tell
five-year-olds to stop eating [ __ ]
shop and I went back and ever since I
was lucky that the local team I was dead
like like the first team was already in
the Bundesliga or they call it in
Germany and so I grew up and grew and
then obviously I went under 10 and 11
and then when I was under 15 and I got
caught up at a German national team and
then it got quite serious because I knew
hey you selected for the best players in
Germany or you got called up for that
did you have a sense that you could play
at the highest levels or were you still
young insecure trying to be humble like
before that which it becomes so obvious
it's undeniable take me to the year
before that did you have a sense or were
you just aloof or where you focused on
it like where was your mindset before
that call-up no before the corner I was
quite confident because I'd really saw
that is easy for me
compete against one or two year older
players writing them down there were
good players good players but then when
I made it to the German Under 15's and I
remember it was players like Thomas
Milla sent them know you know so then I
had started to do that I don't know if I
can make it but you know stay focused
and whatever and he hadn't helped me a
lot because all of these insecurities
told me to train harder and go out a bit
less you know you started 16 17 the
others in the world and all this stuff
as the guys know and so but yeah then
when I was 15 I got this invitation from
Freiburg which is the best youth academy
I would say in Germany and my parents
they told me Danny I think you should
take this opportunity because when from
a lot of my friends back then you know
they drifted apart and like so I was at
ocean yeah it was a bit of a rough you
know upbringing yeah so for my
development as a football player was the
best because I lived there paid for my
school depends on food
my parents didn't really have to worry
about me anymore and yeah so I had this
education from 15 to 19 and I'm not 10
years before we get into questions
before I switched the topic to things
around the sport and marketing and
attention and other things that I like
to talk about when you think about your
professional career what are the one or
two things that stand out the most
definitely my first date which was on TV
because I could just see my parents in
the ground and Emma crying and
everything so I was like I was so
nervous that I didn't sleep the night
before like I had to go to toilet my
stomach is like almost like now but like
I don't try to focus again but it was a
big game because when I was playing for
Freiburg we panic and stood guard that's
a big rivalry they have and so right out
the gate your first match is like a head
a big Radi and still got that Blair's
like Alec Sunderland said Mika tiara
parco crack me up you know like claw
loaded players that was all night I
would say 29 is almost like almost 10
years ago and so I was so nervous like
the first five ten minutes I remember
coming and I was just diving on the
floor tonight at least impossible it was
so good
ten minutes I set it down and took a
deep breath or whatever and I just
thought to myself listen enjoy life you
know if like 25,000 people watching you
and all your friends that watch you on
TV and where I'm from not a lot of
people then make it out to me so I
thought you know what that is not that
bad even if you make a few mistakes it's
your first game I mean come on like yes
it's normal and then that was definitely
one of the proudest moments and I would
say and a proud moment was when we
played against Brazil yes with the
states and I scored I scored a goal
against Brazil you know like every kid
dreams about my playing against Percy
Spain like Greenland normal and so that
was the proper moment and I remember I
was playing against Emma and the funny
story to it is that familiar I used to
play with him and Hoffenheim he just
caught up to the present national team
so yeah was it was quite intense but I
was very proud so talk to me about now
you as a person in a category that I
love a lot which is social media where
you know obviously I've looked at your
Instagram and things that make sure
where do you today sit with with social
media what do you use what do you like
how do you like it like how do you think
about it how do you think about it as if
athlete how do you think about it as a
guy how do you think about it well and
as there are advantages and
disadvantages of course but what are the
advantages advantages the woman
[Laughter]
you are definitely knocking you can I
mean like we're quite like a public
person like you know us from playing the
Premier League and they see us on TV or
whatever and some people they they trust
you by the way you look or whatever and
what I like about social media is that
you can actually show yourself on the
different side other interest you have
making fashion or whatever right and
also you can still control what you want
people to see because I would not
necessarily put on a meal with my with
my family or whatever industry because
it's at the end of the day of social
media it's you're in control right you
in control about up you know painting a
more complete picture about yourself
you're in control that it's not somebody
commentating on you and your play and
your social life it's you projecting it
what what platforms do you use I use
Instagram I use Facebook I use Twitter
and how do you use them differently what
do you space booked for that that's
interesting to me so be honest with your
facebook like I used to have a private
account you know I had like people
running it for me yep like your family
like the fanpage and me and I just
started to
a bit more fun Instagram because I think
it's just newer and like it's more for
the idea and more than younger
generation y'know so and what about
Twitter to identify gravity who's
running it for me too and basically what
I put um Instagram and similar to what I
put on my Twitter do you engage ever or
are you just consuming it's like ensue
yeah they like because I'd end of the
day what I don't like is when we lose
the game
anybody know you suck and people say is
that that's a cool like running you into
that but like I feel if you lose and you
post a picture to this after about you
enjoying a meal and you know whatever
they're like why should [ __ ] focus on
the game yeah I'm human being fair
enough I get it uh talk to me about just
so it's because it's so current
obviously the u.s. national team wasn't
involved but how did you process the
World Cup do you did you go who were you
rooting for how did you think about it
obviously Germany underperformed England
performed extremely well you know you
know
have you had any pump did you go not it
okay did you want to go over he just
couldn't go
you had an orange of fight cuz because
it was salty about not being in it right
respect who do you think was gonna win
for real who did you think was gonna
make a fan to place a bet it would be
Spain over soon right and so how do you
think it played out what will caught
your attention most about this year's
tournament I think the team which
surprised me the most was in Croatia of
course because they have amazing
technical plans but when you see the
size of the country just over it is
exactly so that they came that are like
who's been today yeah so what about
technology as a whole and then I'm gonna
open it up so for the questions for I've
been in the audience like you want to
get very nerdy about proper football do
your thing enjoy it if you want to ask
me a question about business stuff fine
wherever you want to go we're here for
you before we open up to the questions
technology as a whole
having Analects at your home like the
way you watch TV like how much TV do you
watch so when you do watch TV is it
sports is it movies is it Netflix is how
do you how do you all most of the times
that face it and what are you watching
reasons why yeah yeah you and a lot of
other people
and some people had me do watching a
non-violent guilty pleasures obviously
well what about gaming do you play
mobile games do you play fifa
do you play fortnight are you doing
anything in gaming I used to play fifa a
lot of men used to play it for Evolution
Soccer yeah but I have to say that
doesn't interest me no more yes are no
us footballers we have this like weird
like you know means we go to practice
like every morning and people think we
don't do anything but we actually do and
then we come home and I don't have the
energy energy to actually go and sit
down like in whatever like that I just
like to children Netflix or like talk to
friends or meet with friends and you
actually connect with them instead of
sorry like you know what's that are you
whatever are yeah back to the network
with people like in life yeah I think
that's what we're supposed to do is do
as well I like that how do you actually
I apologize one more question before I
open it up how do you think about your
host athletic career like what are your
ambitions when you're done with playing
well I started
properties when I was coming here so on
for property is now in London and I was
actually having a meeting with one of my
people Mike you know the companies who
work for me and we went through it and
obviously like one of these questions
was actually what you going to ask for
pollen I think what I want to focus more
on is like rehab centers because I was
quite unfortunate to my career with
injuries and I think there's so much
more space and you know development
which we can do especially in the UK to
improve rehabilitation so that's what
more do you think about where do you
think about living well I thought about
that I'm not Los Angeles like that we
did not hit do like London yeah
definitely that because I used to live
it for four years yes and it's close to
home because my parents obviously the
different journeys to see I did one half
I was flying so we want to school here
you know think about splitting your time
they attack I love it yeah great who's
got questions
yes like massively like it was quite
intimidating because within a club and
they say to you to do the biggest talent
right so you think okay I'm gonna go
there and I'm gonna rip it up but then
you actually play with some players from
different counties you know different
animals from the same country and it's
like okay you have actually plants
they're better than you and then you
start to realize okay maybe another
sport or whatever so who's the person
who's the first player you ever came
across even if it was when you were five
or when it was this big jump where you
were like holy [ __ ] like even if it's
somebody famous or if it's some person
that never made it do you recall the
first time you came across a player that
you were just like this is different to
advance this it was I'm sorry Tony Cruz
when I played against him in the youth I
was like this [ __ ] is something else and
was it the speed no not because of the
speed because I think I'm too good at
him and I'm just the way he leaves the
ball and like it's phenomenal everything
is just crazy in the talent the raw
talent he has and also messages who some
people like me to say that but he gets a
lot of state which I understand because
of this body language and the way he
carries himself you know what stood out
to you when you first crossed his path
with him it was just his calmness like I
think I played against him and he was
probably 18 18 19 and I think you
playful manner Bremen the time and he
was just like how he moved the ball and
everything he actually took the game in
his hands already and he was 19 and
everybody who ever played football they
know how tough it is to control the game
especially when you're a young player
because I mean you have the confidence
that you are people to believe in you to
getting the ball and stuff and the way
he created the chances and has I think
he's always two three steps ahead of you
like he knows it the game is playing out
of here actually and that's like he
really surprised me very cool questions
yes sir the question is how are you able
to overcome the inevitable pessimistic
you know cynicism like when you when you
know at some point whether you were 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 you're saying I'm gonna
be a professional for quite low how were
you able to not hear your friend or your
uncle or a neighbor I think for a lot of
us I think it maps to everything in life
how are you able to shut out the noise
what was it inside of you parenting
results somebody why were you able to
always you know because there's no way
you end up to where you are without at
every insecurity be able to say no I'm
gonna get over this hump versus I'm
gonna go this way or I can't get over to
hump or let me go backwards for me was
quite easier they washed Connor in
Brenna's elementary you know he always
speaks about
yes and I have to admit the minute I was
I had a bottom line Michael Murphy's I
knew I just visualized it in my head
like I'm going to be preparing a
professional football player and it
sounds weird but I always had this
belief and I saw myself kicking a ball
in the stadium and was crazy when I
played my first game and my parents they
stood there crying I visualized that are
like 17 years yeah you know I mean did
your parents look the way you visualize
them 17 years earlier actually you know
it's why I'm asking you that I would
argue I do a lot of similar things and
they're just premonitions it's not very
clear but I always laugh that the people
at the time look the way they look then
and I always think it's funny because 20
years later they much older and it looks
different but it looks different than it
was in your mind
I get that and also like I just said to
your parents blindly on board was like
would your mom
a lot of trouble when I have enough like
mine when I moved to this Academy my mom
she was diagnosed with breast cancer and
cancer and my dad had like alcoholic
problems and Brahma he was in a lot of
trouble so like when from is you know
not the easiest but I always said to
myself I want to be the one who stands
out from that them didn't want to make
them proud and I want to make myself
talk because end of the day I don't only
have to prove that stuff to myself when
you're going through those kind of
difficulties at such a young age was the
pitch was the field a escape from all
the [ __ ] definitely no it was the
medicine yeah I always felt free when I
was on the pitch like a solution what's
going on yeah the family would devour it
when I the minute I stepped my foot on
the page gone it's gone I'm free so and
then it's funny because when I had more
anger when my parents when they were
fighting you know
right two three hours before before game
I would play better because I was so
angry and I just said on the pitch
I understand questions yes sir
I'm gonna repeat that it's a great
question thank you for that the question
is as fans we are now especially in the
new digital age yearning for aspiring
hoping that it could be a 24/7 thing in
the locker room after the met we want to
watch you eat dinner and after the match
of what you're talking about
we want that access as a player how do
you feel about that not against it
because I love going in the dressing
room and you know having been done with
the boys and it's just like so different
from the outside world because even with
some friends I have and they don't have
to do anything with football they're
just so different like the jokes stuff
they love about different things the
power sport is love of course and laughs
so it's so different and I don't have
nothing against it I think let me ask
you a question that I've always been
interested in have there been in the
last three four years as this world has
exploded this always on content world
have there been teams that you've been a
part of that some of the players look
down on the other players that are
spending a lot of time trying to build
their brand on Instagram trying to sign
entrepreneurship is there an animosity
of like this isn't the way we should be
doing it if you were this foot like is
there if they have a you know you talk
about the fans saying hey why are you
eating is there a level of tension in
the locker rooms of you know some guys
doing three public appearances and and
is that a keynote at a tech conference
and isn't playing as well as the
teammate thinks that he should is there
a little bit of that old-school
new-school tension in the locker room
identity I mean you can definitely sense
a difference when it comes to the
doughnut and a range
you know the players who retire or about
to retire another 35 36 they aren't and
you know a player who's 18 19 he just
posts every day post up on his wearing
when using Selfridges when he's doing
that it's like crazy over patent rights
whatever it is and then you can see the
other guys said listen focus on football
I sincerely interpret but that's just
how it is yeah this in this world will
be living at the moment like it's a big
run by social media as well and if you
use it the right way and you can
actually calculate on it as well yes sir
yeah I mean the question just to repeat
it is when you're a smaller company how
do you not get taken advantage of by
bigger companies you know Vayner was a
very small company when I started it and
we worked with the biggest companies in
the world right away with a little bit
of my reputation I'm a very interesting
answer to this it's twofold first of all
when you have your own company and you
have clients you're in control of
whether you're being in taken advantage
of or not if you're a client provider if
you have clients you're more than
welcome to pick up the phone and say I
don't want to work with you anymore and
here's the money back or I don't want
your money anymore
so first of all every small business
just needs to know that that's the great
part of having a business
you're also in charge right number two I
would argue for a lot of small
businesses the goal is to be taking
advantage of I think about the first
three to four years of vaynermedia very
similar to the way Mohammed Ali fought
George Foreman in Zaire I think I wrote
a doped the industry I think the
industry thought they were taking
advantage of Boehner and they weren't we
were doing so much more work for the
money they were paying me versus the
companies that were much bigger than us
when we started I also think that's why
I let it happen because that was the
value prop that we didn't have
reputation I was a wine shop owner now
in in you know and social media was not
what it is
today when I started Vayner in 2009 most
of our clients thought that you know it
was a fad so I think two things one
you're in control and two it's actually
probably the leverage you have and I
think too many small businesses go
ideology on this they've become
ideological about it like oh I'm getting
taken advantage of your big boy it's
your bed you can sleep in it like I
think you need to use it as an offense I
think it is the number one thing that a
small tiny business has over a big
business that needs to make more profit
that needs to be you know publicly
traded in hit numbers I think every
small business should I watching
Patrick Vieira nor is pressed invincible
theory and they just create so much
history that I think it was
for that Club try everything to bring
the history bank and also make the fans
proud because I know you guys suffer at
the moment with Arsenal you know it's an
interesting topic
I uh I become so fascinated so one of my
one of the things in America that I'm
spending a lot of time making jokes
about on social media is if you live in
New York City and you have a Steph Curry
Jersey on that I think you're a piece of
[ __ ] right so and to me it's I think
you're a piece of [ __ ] not because
you're a bad person but because I think
it's a I think it's a very interesting
psyche of when you pick a team either
based on the history or the current
winning status or when you pick an
underdog I find it I'm interested I
don't understand why why do I hate Kobe
Bryant until the last year of his career
when he's a little more washed up then I
root for him why in every situation on
any match of any sort something I don't
even understand if I randomly end up
looking this actually happened one day
I'm clicking through my son's getting
into sports so I'm trying to get him
into everything I don't want to impose
my my opinions on him I want him to
taste things and there's a cricket match
I can tell you one thing about Americans
you don't think they understand proper
football we really don't understand
cricket right yeah I'm like what the
[ __ ] anyway look hitting it backward I'm
like is anyway it's on I literally
Google while the match is on to figure
out which team is the favorite and then
I spend the next ten minutes desperately
reading for the underdog and I'm very
interested in when I started announcing
when we open this office that I wanted
to pick a team I'm fascinated that like
99% of people are fans of the same four
to five teams right we all know who they
are in the same way in the u.s. whether
it's the Lakers or you know or baseball
the Yankees the psyche of people that
want to jump on bandwagons versus the
psyche of the people that want to pick
something and pick an Under
as in Iraq the biggest reason I'm not a
hundred percent locked into the Spurs is
my only criteria for picking my team was
that they couldn't have won the
championship in the last 40 years the
problem with the Spurs is they haven't
but they're very [ __ ] bougie you know
and like like I'm very confused by it it
doesn't map to my Jets and Knicks fandom
as well as I'd like it to so I'm still
trying to figure my [ __ ] out but but
yeah I just basically think that all of
you that jump on good teams when you
live in a town that has a team that
you're actually a loser
yeah no championship in 40 years all
right
yes and before you for the question is
you've been on this interesting journey
for a young man 29 years old was there a
tipping point where you took control of
your life based on the interview we've
been doing I'm curious are you coming
from the perspective of the adversity he
faced when he was a youngster like add a
layer to that question so I'm curious
where you're going or maybe the
investments you know not every young man
is pouring his money into investment
properties versus a Lamborghini
well the first time I started to realize
that had to do something with the money
[Music]
went to London when I start a bit
already because it was to mention like I
have my my friends and anybody in
Germany and then I'm in Vegas and my
agent calls me is in a dead heat
I have an offer for you and I was well
okay and he goes yeah but it's not in
Germany it's like you have to leave the
country Americans in there and I was
like cool where is it and he goes it's
already and how spike where do I live
and he goes you could live in la niñas
okay you know what aquinas containers
person and i think the people in germany
bit uptight so I think I care about my
captain and the way I have myself I
think it in small anyways to this
sitting here so that you know what I'm
hoping to do that and so I was in a
hotel room
and reading and I had nobody calling me
like there was obviously my mom my dad
they they messaged me whatever I was put
on the spot no car no bank account set
up yet let nothing and I was thinking
like well how old were you guys 24 okay
I was like with all the people you know
they don't even see me anymore Germany's
Orana Brenneman in like I still have to
live and I have to find it I don't know
people I socialize it so she might
because that's the most important always
if I'm not happy I don't perform well
and so then moved to London and I
started to real quick I apologize yeah
you say if I'm not happy I don't perform
well I assume in the macro because
earlier in the micro you said if my
parents are fighting before the match I
play better
is that a macro micro thing or was that
an evolution when you were younger that
work for you but over time as you grew
up
it changed thing is Legos either parents
by the parents fighting is one thing but
I also didn't have Evo my socialite
thing okay I said I was heavy so their
social life is good
yes I very from the hillside I got it
then I was very select and it shows on
the pinch but when they thought I can
let the hang out as well so I got it
okay that was the traffic the book yeah
exactly their social life was killing it
their parents are fighting [ __ ]
dominate exactly one make sure um no but
then I started to hang out with people
who would seem a bit more boring boring
to the type of friends I used to have
but actually more interesting because he
pulled me same as Danny listen we signed
a great contract with reading four years
that's actually big security and you
have to start to either buy something
alone because the city is one of the
leading cities in the world you know
state capital and whatever so the
property market I think usually nine
times out of ten the price will go up
and like you know you have to just
generate another income of four when you
when you're done with playing football
and I said to him okay never heard about
that because the friends I used to have
they just didn't they didn't write my
own stuff like that so I said you know
what I'm gonna I'm going to rent a place
in West London
and see get to know the area and then
after here on the site where I wanna
invest and I think that guy he helped me
a lot and our always be grateful for
that because looking now I almost paid
all of the flats off and Sam I already
generate income and the places are
rented out so I'm I'm happy that's a
good place out there
yes in the back okay I'll get you next
yes yeah yeah the question is will there
be a pushback a lash against social you
know time spent the privacy issues I
think it's already happened right you
really see companies coming out you know
look look at Apple Apple is a company
that's not winning in social right
there's apps on top of their app
platform but there they're not in it and
so if you're Apple you're saying we
build a default device on our phone that
warns you of how much screen time there
might be a way for us to use that as
defense to play as an offense right
I think the privacy thing is a really
interesting one whether it spreads that
our Trump or many other things that are
going on I think we as human beings
don't like to hold ourselves accountable
and so I do think there'll be a backlash
against social but I think it's gonna be
more of us passing on responsibilities
of things that we don't want to see in
ourselves I think parents are very good
at judging Millennials without realizing
they're the ones who raise them and
created the entitlement so I think the
human condition speaks to I believe the
people that tend to win the most in life
are the ones that are most willing to be
accountable and I believe that the
masses do not want to be accountable and
I do believe that the mainstream media
has a lot of financial reasons to
downplay the digital world because it's
taking their money and I think that all
these dynamics are playing out so I
think there'll be a backlash now
I think it'll be a blip on the screen I
think that we are going towards you know
when my friends are like oh I'm limiting
my sons you know screen time I'm like
you do know what world your son will
live in in 15 years right just want to
make sure everybody knows we won't be
going backwards
this wait wait - voices mature and
you're talking to your LexA like it's
your friend you know way to AR and VR
and all these things continue like the
robots are gonna kill us in the end you
know and so I don't you know to me it
will be a month it'll be a micro blip
three years six years six months but I
think you know when the whole Facebook
Cambridge analytical thing happened
people were posting protests of Facebook
on Instagram like it was just the most
fun thing for me to watch the human can
is like [ __ ] you Facebook on Instagram
which it owns and so you know III think
that uh I think we will but I don't
think it means anything in the
inevitable macro of Technology
advancement technology always wins like
because we value convenience over
everything we are we are animals that
value time subconsciously and we will
give up everything including money and
that's what we spend our money on by the
way if you play it out so yeah cirebon
yeah
[Music]
okay the questions is for everybody
watching camera difference between the
German and American national team and
who do you want the next American coach
to be of the American national team how
would we do when you're on the German
team in how old were you on the American
team I played me I was 17 17 18 and then
I started to play her it is a when I was
21 I give God so the biggest difference
it is definitely the education in like
tactically technically because if I look
at this like years used the country is
so much bigger than than Germany right
and I think the US has amazing athletes
but they just don't know how to use you
know their speed the power strength
because outside we have better athletes
than the Germans in general just like
you can see you know like sprinters and
whatever there's never a German guy
winning but they focus so much on
technically and tactical work they
actually invest a lot of money in
research as well because the youth
cultures they then fly to Barcelona they
go to Amsterdam we're all an amazing
academies are and they learn from them
whereas in the state's I think because
it's not the number one sport of the
country and then I'm really interested
in in
then they don't like to be bad in
something which now since we didn't make
the work up changed a lot I think that's
one of the more investment one for
American soccer now what about coach
coach so I think with the interim Scott
at the moment they've Saracen and he's
doing an amazing job I have to say I
mean we drew against France just a month
before they won the World Cup right and
he definitely changed the strategy of
players scouting and recruitment and he
focuses a lot more on the younger
players than in the past you had a lot
of politics going on
for whatever reasons which I kind of bit
slack off because I came out and said it
but yeah there were players who already
has her prior past their prime like
Germany now you see because they won the
World Cup four years ago people thought
that some players and players still have
to start every game and that was wrong
and that happened with the states and it
cost us to work happy so I just hope
that the next manager will be someone
who focuses in on early youth and makes
decisions for poor base than that
political base I think it's you know
from somebody from a very outside point
of view in the sport but who watches
culture very carefully I think the most
interesting thing about u.s. football in
the long term is two core things one
it's that just the popularity of the
sport is real like you if you spend time
in America fifteen years ago I never saw
a single kid in America where a soccer
jersey it never happened now you see as
many kids you know six to twelve wearing
football jerseys as you do see them wear
baseball or outside a basket little
football are still number one but
baseball and hockey and proper football
are now hovering around the same
popularity number two the Latino
population in the u.s. is so extreme and
exploding that I think the last names
will look more like Brazil or Mexico or
things of that nature
in 16 or 20 years but the resources are
there it just it's not religion like
LeBrons playing basketball not defense
you know that's so I think that uh
advance will be interesting to watch
over the next 20 years all right one
more question
what are you accused of culture yes yes
well recently featured game and a movie
as you've got your new one system
culture when it comes to the building of
business in America in the UK will you
align yourself with UK rappers as a
source of learning the culture that
cakes and sketch Jamie and my question
is yes what new one says will you be
looking for when you talk to those
artists to teach you things about things
yes so what my dear friend here who's
known me for a long time knows I've
always really loved hip-hop as my
Instagram over the last two years has
exploded in parallel Mike Boyd who's
always been close to me was freed up to
really do strategy for me and we took
approach about 18 months ago to get very
serious about the emerging hip-hop
artists that we thought in a 5 to 7 year
window could become the drakes or low
means and what would that mean and get
in the trenches of culture the question
is am I thinking about that in a UK lens
as well and it's kind of interesting
because maybe you've noticed this and
it's probably why not probably it's why
we're sitting here right now I've taken
the approach in the UK and we're opening
up Singapore in February we're gonna
open up Brazil it looks like now and
2019 as well it's interesting my
ambition to get deeper into proper
football having you know a son and
daughter that I want to like have a team
and go through it knowing that I'm gonna
be your six or 10 times a year handy
because I think authenticity matters
because I've historically not gravitated
to the artists that you just mentioned
I've actually taken the macro thesis of
what emerging hip-hop are
you for me in a pulse of culture in the
u.s. I think the culture of Premier
League and and proper football culture
in the UK and Europe as a whole is the
way I'm thinking about that I'm trying
to spend time and listen and pay
attention I spend an enormous amount of
time looking in the u.s. maybe world
star as a Instagram account but for the
way I'm thinking about Europe and the UK
in general you know it'll be four three
three that I'll spend more time looking
at and so interestingly especially given
that we're sitting here together the
approach is not going to be emerging
hip-hop artists in the UK unless just
like everything in my life one artist
catches my imagination at the right time
you know this almost everything you love
food sports whatever maybe it was one
thing that then that you fell in love
with the rack URIs about that got you
deep into the rabbit hole so I wouldn't
say never I allow for a lot of
serendipity but I also am thoughtful and
have a lot of strategy I think the
culture of football here is one of the
spending a lot of time on both selfishly
because I want to suck myself into it
because I want to get into it and
because I think it is an incredible
important currency of the culture
Merryn why I show you when you have
someone that you're gonna sneak it in by
giving the influence or a hundred
percent autonomy and eliminating our
egos as brands and thinking that we know
exactly what it stands for and what it
means I think the what the biggest
iOpener to me in corporate America and a
brand world is the level of ideology and
audacity and ego like the thought that
like for all the normal people here
coca-cola and Heineken and Adidas think
that the brand means the same thing to
all of you and that's just laughable
everybody here when I say the word
supreme or you know Kentucky Fried
Chicken or thinking different things
discussing awesome rad I don't know what
that is that and so there's a there's an
ideology that brand managers and CMOS in
corporate America have about what their
brand stands for if you're gonna do
influencer marketing what you need to do
is you need to buy sponsorship through
influencers at a good deal they know
their audience he if he decided you want
to do that I any of you you know your
audience and so if your interpretation
of this chocolate shake or sneaker or
you know blow dryer is it needs to be
funny and snarky that's exactly as a
brand what you want you're giving him me
somebody that's money so that you have
something happened for your business
Stella wants business the best thing for
Stella to do is get out of the way they
much like the small business question
they're in charge of picking him you
picked the influencer you've decided
that influencer is somebody I want
because she's so [ __ ] awesome I want
to give her money so I sell [ __ ] why
don't you micromanaging her and telling
her like you better use the word great
I've never used the word I've never done
a sponsorship deal in my life and I big
audiences there's a couple reasons it's
not how I think about my brand and it's
not what I do
but even a case like the case listing
that's a partnership right but when I
signed my case was ill the most
interesting part of the negotiation was
the standard deal do you have a sneaker
deal hey great so the standard deal is
like [ __ ] you don't
or anything else the I literally at the
11th hour walked from the case whiskey
oh because I wanted to wear whatever I
wanted to wear like if I wanted to wear
Air Force Ones which I like to wear
quite a bit like I didn't want I needed
the authenticity of me I didn't need the
economics enough and I think that's the
best influence or not the worst you know
because we smell out [ __ ] we're very
very good at it you know you could trick
us for a minute you know not for an hour
and definitely not for a year and so I
think that um I think Brandt brands need
to check their egos and get out of the
way
much like I told that young man you're
in control you can say no I don't want
to work with you anymore right brands
don't have to pick the influencer but
once they pick it they need to get out
of the way let the influencer or do
their thing that's the reason you picked
them in the first place
thank you thanks everyone for being here
let's clap it up
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering awesome thank you guys
[Music]